what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man yes we are the
books of quarterback part two and this
one we're just going to cover the whole
volume right we're not going to worry
about
splitting it in a little section things
like that but coming out of the last
video that we did
basically corvac had launched an attack
against patsy walker and
iron man and essentially incapacitated
them both which is just kind of a sheer
display of the power of michael korvac
so much so that tony stark's entire suit
is just shut down right i mean it's just
it's
literally been overloaded the rest of
the team writes like misty knight and
frog man
i love frogman so like frogman gargoyle
those guys they're all kind of
recovering they were able to help sort
of guard people a little bit gargoyle's
kind of recovering himself right just
because of the fact that he lost a wing
sustained huge injuries different things
like that
it's basically recovery time and so when
you end up picking back up with tony
stark uh what you end up getting here
is this this really cool moment where
they basically start to kind of
work on him as best they can but they
can't really do a whole lot and the
reason why
is because of the injury that he
sustained this is one of those
interesting things about iron man suit
is that if they were to move him they
would like his his neck is like one bad
position away from killing him right
it's already broken right so in order to
keep him stabilized like having a neck
harness in the form of a suit they have
to actually modify the collar on his
suit so his body doesn't move and it's
one of the crazy things because he's
like under any normal circumstance he
would have this tended to
they would get it taken care of but
michael korvac trying to return to power
is no small thing now
again because of the fact that this is
an iron man story under any normal
circumstance you would have him enlist
the aid of the avengers the guardians of
the galaxy the whole nine yards but
christopher cantwell is going in the
direction of saying like
this is just a tony stark story so is
tony stark just dealing with it on his
own so obviously this seems like it's
gonna end in such a way to where
quarterback's gonna obviously be
defeated and he's not gonna become some
massive calamity right some universal
wide threat or anything along those
lines but in the midst of all this
suddenly they're met by the arrival of
james rhodes and james rhodes is kind of
the voice of reason here right donning
the war machine suit he's like look we
got to get the avengers in on this and
the response of stark is that's not
going to happen
right i mean you do have one of the
henchmen of quarterback who shows up
tries to instigate a fight he gets taken
out pretty quickly but the whole idea
behind james rhodes is
fine if this is really going to be the
case and this is just going to be a you
i've got to take care of it on my own
this is a personal vendetta kind of
thing
then that's fine like at the very least
i can come along and make sure that you
don't get yourself killed right that
kind of a thing now again people will
kind of look at that and say it's a
little weird
that that camp wells turning this what
is basically a character who is a cosmic
entity right michael korvac at the peak
of his power
was wildly powerful he could reshape the
universe as he so chose
based on his use of the power cosmic
right the power of galactus a lot of
people will look at that and say
it's weird that cantwell's just turning
this into an iron man story i think it's
cool i think it's cool to have a
character who is such a massive cosmic
level threat that's not turning into
yet another big crossover event in
marvel comics right where crossover
events happen all the time but instead
it's being held in the the kind of
capacity where it's facing off against
iron man this is old school right this
is like 1970s 1980s marvel comics so
while i'm not necessarily some old
school hipster and i wish things could
go back to the way they were 50 years
ago
i don't i do like the idea that we get
these kind of little moments here where
you get these small stories where what
would normally be
a giant avengers class threat probably
even a universal threat involving a
whole host of
space faring characters and everything
instead of just being dealt with by iron
man so there's a couple things that you
get here which is kind of cool you end
up of course getting them
you know boarding tony stark ship
basically taking off after michael
korvac uh war machine gets a giant
upgrade so does tony stark we're not
really given the definitive nature of
war machines upgrade we're just
told that he gets one and that's that's
really kind of it but you actually have
this really cool moment where you end up
having
patsy walker who's basically brought in
alongside tony stark by michael korvec
of course
using his his powers and so on basically
kind of communicates to them that like
this sort of lush planet right this lush
beautiful planet
is is kind of a physical manifestation a
representation of the utopia that he
wants to bring to the universe and again
this is one of the things we talk about
in like injustice and different things
like that
that if humanity and even just the
entirety of the universe's denizens
wanted the universe to be a better place
it would be but the fact that it's not
is an indication to the fact that they
don't want it to be
whether it's by their own inaction or
their direct action and keeping that
from happening
apathy or intentional cause the result
is that people want things to be bad
and so at the end of the day korvac is
kind of really appearing him you know as
this kind of guy that's saying look the
universe is going to become a better
place
whether you want it to or not right like
war disease famine all that kind of
stuff hate fear
it's all going away i know a lot of you
guys want it to stay but it's not going
to right it's all going to be eliminated
and it's kind of a funny thing because
one of the things that we've seen is
that in the face of that
superheroes almost stand in the way of
making things better right that if
the world and the universe is a crappy
place because people out there want it
to be
then in turn superhero's saying no they
should have the right to choose whether
or not the universe is good or bad
standing in the face of the guy who's
going to say like i'm using all this
power
to make the world a better place is in
effect standing in the way
of making the universe a better place
right so they're literally working
against
progress like they're literally working
against the universe becoming a utopia
the argument that they argue that they
really present here is no one person can
have that power and the argument that's
really presented here is based on
michael korvac's previous escapades
which is his desire to kind of lay waste
to everything so on and so forth which
was not necessarily true the funny thing
about this is that michael korvak is
more machine than man so he's not really
encumbered by emotion
and really emotion is the source of
virtually every bad decision
anybody's ever made right emotional
decisions are inherently bad decisions
logical decisions are inherently the
best decisions right
what's best for the greatest number of
people the greatest number of people
having peace and prosperity and not
having to worry about pain and suffering
that's what's best for the universe
so we're gonna do that right it's it's a
it's an interesting concept right it
really
is this kind of you know freedom versus
security argument that's being presented
here and so because what you get is iron
man
and essentially patsy walker standing in
the face of that the whole thing is just
kind of dispersed
and iron man is just teleported to some
weird location right just kind of sent
away where he's met by what's called the
colony patrol now we'll talk about them
here in a little bit but what you end up
doing here is switching over and really
picking up with like korvac and his guys
chasing after you know james rhodes and
you know trying to destroy their ship so
they can't get in the way of his mission
and all that kind of crazy stuff but in
the midst of all that suddenly patsy
walker is met by a telepathic
communication
which actually turns out to be coming
from moon dragon now
heather douglas is interesting heather
douglas is cool she's probably one of
the more important characters in the
history of marvel comics
she is a hugely powerful telepath right
she has all kinds of wild abilities at
least on a telepathic level and really
depending on who's been writing the
story over the years if you go and you
look at the old school like jim starlin
stuff she was telepathically powerful on
a universal scale right if you look at
the more recent stories like dan abner
annihilation annihilation conquest she's
not necessarily on that same level of
power but she still
is immensely powerful more so than that
her and patsy walker have an interesting
relationship
in the sense that in years past when
paxy walker had these powers
and it basically started driving her
insane that moon dragon was the one who
shut those powers off
and so what moondragon has done is
realizing that because corvac is
returning here they really kind of need
all hands on deck and patsy walker's
ability to emanate telepathic abilities
or to the very least
to ride the radio waves of telepathic
powers is exceedingly important here and
in fact that's actually what saves the
day because while you do get this whole
thing where you get like the backstory
of patsy walker none of it really
matters her powers are basically woken
up right and so when you have korvac in
these guys who are basically chasing
down james rhodes and all them she uses
her powers to essentially spawn
illusions in the face of michael korvac
of the badoon right like his really is
his worst fear in a lot of different
ways
we'll talk about why here in a second
but spawns you know illusions of the
badoon which really distracts
quarterback and everybody else enough to
where they basically
stop dead in their tracks which gives
james rhodes and everybody the ability
to kind of fire up their engines
and take off as fast as they can right
now following that you kind of pick up
with this whole quarterback thing right
this whole
really discussion with with quarterbacks
so this really starts in the year 2997
right the quarterback is from a
far-flung future and technically an
alternate reality depending on how you
want to look at it but the important
thing is that by this point in time the
badoon have conquered a huge section
of the of the universe and it actually
set their sights on earth and so what
you had at that point was essentially a
rebel faction right these kind of
individuals out there who were looking
to stop the badoon from essentially
conquering earth at that point a lot of
humanity or at least some portion of
humanity worked for the badoon really
more as servants and slaves than
anything else but the big thing is that
quarterback shows up here as part of
their ranks and then kills them all
only to find out that he's working for
the badoon right he's working directly
for them and that has essentially
you know eliminated this kind of faction
this this you know uh
really rebel regiment to ensure that
there's no real resistance nobody to
warn earth that an invasion of the
badoon is coming now again
at this point in time korvac was really
just an employee right and we're really
just like a servant working for the
badoon themselves and so what ended up
happening is that because he abandoned
his station
and didn't do what he was supposed to
right didn't stay there what they ended
up doing was taking
his human components and basically
merging them with cybernetic components
and so he was one part man one part
machine he was a cyborg and he had the
ability to interface
with machines this was the explanation
marvel provided as to
how he became as powerful as he was that
in the original michael korvac
saga way back in the way back in the day
in marvel that what he did is he
actually traveled to the world ship of
galactus to tattoo
and then quote unquote downloaded the
power cosmic and that's what made him so
powerful that's what he's looking to do
again right so this is not michael
korvac who's been recreated
as a character who just kind of exists
right just kind of a copy of
his former self this is actually michael
korvac who's been brought back
and that's kind of a cool thing now
something that's a little wonky is that
along the way
to the the world ship of galactus
they're kind of recruiting allies and
one of the places they they travel to is
this world that's largely kind of been
been far-flung and cast off only to find
the original human towards jim hammond
now the events that led to him being
here
really come out of like the invaders
comics we haven't really covered those
although they are pretty good
we may cover them at some future point
in time but one of the big changes that
kind of comes out of this one of the
things that's kind of given here
is that with korvac it's kind of a weird
blend michael korvac was basically
reinstated or brought back by the
enclave who created adam warlock and
called him adam but they call korvac
adam one and the weird thing here is
that that korvac basically refers to jim
hammond as essentially being adam four
and so in essence it's almost as though
cantwell is kind of blending
the old phineas horton origin for
creating jim hammond with like the
enclave and creating adam warlock almost
kind of blending them together now as
far as i'm aware
phineas horton was never part of the
enclave he never joined the enclave
right he was not really
hell-bent on on trying to conquer the
world through science if anything he was
just obsessed with getting credit for
having created the first android but
regardless of how you how you slice it
here
because of the fact that jim hammond is
an android korvac approaches him because
he believes he's best suited
to truly understand what the mission of
korvac is right quarvax desire to bring
peace and prosperity and so what you end
up having is the two of them traveling
together and korvac of course
upgrades the body of jim hammond giving
him enhanced abilities but
at the same time hooks him up to uh do a
system that basically allows him to
process and to see
what it is that quarterback is looking
to do now the two of their minds are
connected right because as machines they
can transfer information back and forth
in the same way you transfer information
from a computer to a usb drive and so
what this does is it basically shows the
the kind of corvac
events whereby the avengers approach and
they ask about what's going on you know
and they try to stop him from what it is
that he's doing and he basically ends up
killing the avengers in the process and
one of the things is that when this
happens
jim hammond turns on him and again this
is kind of a funny thing because the
reality is whenever you're instituting a
giant cause like this right like
bringing peace and prosperity to those
who don't want it they're going to try
to stop it and so as a result of that
you're going to have to move them out of
the way right there are going to be
forces out there that were going to be
roadblocks in your way
and ultimately if the ends truly do
justify the means and because of their
own natures they're incapable of seeing
it then you just have to get rid of them
right you literally just that's the only
thing that you can do
if you cannot convince them if you
cannot get them to understand where
you're coming from if you try everything
you can
which is literally what quarterback's
been doing and at the end of the day
they just refuse to accept the reality
of the situation then the only
alternative is to eliminate them right
to remove them from the equation
and then continue on your goal to peace
and prosperity it's literally happened
across the entirety
of of civilization and so because of
this corvette comes to this realization
that jim hammond will never really ally
himself with him and so where a
controller disc is put on hammond to
kind of keep him under control
it really is a little crushing to korvac
because he wasn't looking for a servant
right he wasn't looking for a slave he
was looking for an ally somebody that
could truly understand where he was
coming from
and truly help him help him achieve this
goal and so it's kind of an interesting
thing here because having the power of
jim hammond is no small thing right the
original human torch this guy's not
necessarily on the same power level as
the human towards johnny storm but he is
pretty damn powerful right he's pretty
capable and so what you end up doing is
switching over to this planet that iron
man
is currently on and one of the funny
things here is that as he's in this
world and as he's there spending time
with these people
he of course comes across a woman by the
name of yar who's basically the one that
leads the show now yar doesn't have any
real existing history in marvel she's a
new creation for this story
but the environment and the way this
whole place exists it really is by all
standards of measurement what you would
define as a communist society right
there's no money here right there's no
real
noble income or anything like that
they're simply resources and those who
share them now truth to tell if this
society grew large enough you would
either run into a barter system that
would evolve into money or it would just
turn straight into money right you look
at like any
any political philosopher out there and
they will tell you when you go from a
state of nature which is what this is
to an organized society then somehow or
another money money's gonna get involved
right
it's just it's just the nature of us as
the human race we're primitive right we
are pretty primitive and pretty basic
and we haven't quite figured out that
there's more important things in the
world than cash
so because of that the the whole thing
is that tony stark kind of experiences
this sense of belonging that he never
really experienced before right this
sense of community camaraderie he even
goes as far as to say i never got along
with the avengers this well
it's kind of a funny thing now one of
these guys is also colin richards also
known as avro x he appeared back in
marvel fanfare issue number 44 back in
the day he's it's okay i mean he's not a
major character right it's not a great
big huge thing it's not a massive thing
at all
but while tony stark is kind of
exploring the area waiting to be called
forward by
basically the guy who runs the show that
he ends up coming across an
ultimo now the ultimo was nuts now
ultimo was a character who appeared in
tales of suspense number 76 back in
1966. the ultimo was not like the
biggest deal ever when he first showed
up but his time progressed and
especially when characters like the
mandarin got his hands on him he became
a
host right like the the ultimos are
designed to be insanely durable now the
funny thing about this is that
initially the ultimo only had like maybe
30 appearances in marvel comics so
christopher cantwell is by all standards
of measurement working with a blank
slate here he can kind of modify the
history of the ultimo the cc's fit which
is exactly what's going on here we never
really knew where the ultimo came from
we never really knew where it originated
from we just knew that it was there one
day and then it was being used by
different villains and it was operating
of its own accord
it could run it like 100 miles an hour
it stood at like a hundred feet tall
right these things were were colossal in
size but where tony stark realizes that
it is
essentially a machine powered organism
he of course helps to power or power his
own suit
realizing that it's enzymatic along the
way right there are enzymes blended with
this technology so it seems to be partly
biological in nature and so while he
doesn't necessarily pick up
immediately on the fact that it's an
ultimo he realizes like this thing's got
biological components it's really more
of a passing interest than anything else
when suddenly he's met by the arrival of
yar who says like the big guy will see
you now and so when when tony stark gets
there he realizes
it's wilbur day it's the stilt man
so stiltman was created by stan lee and
wally wood in daredevil number eight
back in 1965 he's never been a big time
threat in marvel
comics right i mean he's literally as
you see him that's what he does right
like he originally stole the technology
from his employer a guy named carl
caxton
and then used it for his own ends and he
fought daredevil a little bit ended up
in a bit of a criminal history there but
he was never significant right wilbur
day was never one of those guys where
he's like oh my god here comes stilt man
that was never gonna happen right it's
like okay here comes stilt man well you
know he's he's literally the guy that
like that like daredevil's fighting when
the story opens right just to kind of
show what daredevil's doing at the time
that's basically how stiltman was and
really always has been
in marvel comics but the funny thing is
still man hasn't been seen in marvel for
a long time and that's one of the funny
things here
is that as the two of them are kind of
talking iron man's like damn man like
like it's weird seeing you here his
knowledge of wilbur day is that he only
ever got involved with people if he
could achieve
his own personal end right he's really
just kind of a jerk
and so iron man's whole thing is like
okay so like you're leading this whole
thing what do you get out of this right
like i mean
what's in it for you he expects him to
be this villain that he's familiar with
but one of the things that iron man
quickly learns
is that like there's no room for that
here right that everybody's just trying
to live right they're just like they've
all just kind of been thrust here
teleported here
in the same way that iron man has right
that somewhere along the line something
happened in the blink of an eye they
suddenly woke up here
wilbur day was one of the first but the
character of yarr she was a a
she was a member of the cree army right
like a a cree colonist and was just like
teleported here right
everybody's just kind of been yanked
here somewhere along the line this is
quite literally an island of misfit toys
right that's basically what this is
characters who are minor small
irrelevant never had any major role
and there's no real logic or reason to
why they're here in the first place
honestly i love the cantwell's doing
this it's creative
it's really really creative i thought it
was cool like this never
never would have occurred to me and so
the the fact that everybody's just kind
of been yanked here and they're just
trying to live
in this ecosystem it's cool right
because it's basically
really kind of showing the you know
these people for what they are
if these people really do anything it
solidifies the views of michael korvac
right they're like you can't have a
utopia like you can have this kind of
environment but notice like it's a cast
off these people
never would have lived in this
environment had they not been forced
into it right the circumstances led to
them becoming where they are
or at least kind of living this life
that they're living in right so there
really is legitimacy to korvax argument
here right it's really kind of
interesting because
even iron man finds himself letting his
guard down of course he explains why he
can't take a suit off that if he does
it'll break his neck and he'll die but
like he's just kind of enjoying his life
right i mean he's literally playing
baseball with him right just kind of
enjoying this utopian lifestyle and just
kind of chilling here to the point
that he almost kind of doesn't want to
leave but then suddenly they're met by
the arrival of one of the ultimos who
gets here and that's when you kind of
learn this little bit of a dark history
here when it comes to the ultimos is
that they
one originated from this planet and two
killed the people who created them right
that this
basically seems to be the place where
they originated from and those
individuals
who who created them were ultimately
destroyed and the way in which these
ultimos power themselves
is by basically consuming enzymes right
the reason why they're partly biological
is one of them basically ends up
grabbing yar and then eats her right
like literally consumes her and that's
when iron man realizes
wow like this is this is basically how
it is they're biological
this story has an effect turned into
attack on titan
right those giant robots roaming around
eating people i assume that's what it is
i don't never really watch attack on
well i take that back vinnie over a
comic story and tried to get me into
anime by having me watch attack on titan
it was weird
people keep telling me i should watch it
i mean i've seen like
like full metal alchemist brotherhood
took me a little while to get into it
but you know ultimately i got into it
mariah got me into that
just because of the fact that she
watches it so often i have basically
watched the entire
series of avatar the last airbender even
though i guess it's not technically an
anime
but i saw a bunch of those so i guess i
might as well sit down and watch you
know attack on titan right all these
giant robots who were just eating people
i think it's weird
right it's weird the giant robots are
eating people but hey who am i to
complain about
about anime being weird but nonetheless
[Laughter]
it's one of these funny things because
with this ultimo being destroyed the
reality is that in this environment in
which they've lived that the ultimos are
basically the predators right you know
it's like it's like living in the living
out there in africa and you have to
contend with like lions and different
things like that right those
apex predators that exist in that
ecosystem and then suddenly here comes
iron man
and takes out one of the ultimos right
it's like the the ages of primitive man
when all they could do was run away from
predators and then suddenly men
developed spears right humanity
developed spears we developed fire
things like that tools and resources
that could be used that could elevate us
from from
having been lower on the totem pole to
being the apex predator on earth right
it's really what's being introduced here
a modification to the ecosystem and so
iron man isn't necessarily law as being
like a leader and like taking over the
role of controlling everything but it's
one of these things where it's just kind
of like okay
you know it's like he kind of looks
around he says like so you say there's
more of these things out there but what
you've built here is something beautiful
right like
we shouldn't let those things destroy
this right so what we should do
is go in and take care of it right we
should go handle these things right he's
almost kind of like their their sort of
field command their protector
in a lot of ways because in reality he's
like i like it here right i want to help
you here and again the kind of note
that's left on here by christopher
cantwell is iron man doesn't really seem
to want to leave
he kind of wants to stay so with that
being said guys that wraps up the books
of of corvac
volume two i guess we'll now have to
wait for volume three to come out i'm
loving it right i'm loving what
cantwell's doing with iron man i'm gonna
be honest this is some of the most
enjoyment i've had reading iron man's
comics since uh since really kieran
gillan's run right the secret origin of
tony stark and all that stuff the
introduction of arno and everything
i'm really digging like i'm really
digging i think it's some of the best
iron man writing since then but with
that being said guys let me know what
you guys think down in the comment
section
and i will catch you all later peace